[Musique]
et puis là localement il peut avoir
aussi des effets qui font en sorte que
certains édifices vont s'écrouler
justement par des conditions locales
particulières donc ça a bougé pendant
plusieurs secondes sur une grande
surface
absolument dans certains cas ça aurait
pu être quelques minutes sur ma ou les
vibrations avaient été ressenties par
les gens mais des réparations intenses
sûrement quelques dizaines de secondes
il faut dire que c'est une des zones
sismiques les plus actives du globe
cette région là bien dans la région où
on a eu le séisme d'hier et celui
d'aujourd'hui pas tant que ça dans un
sens si on regarde par exemple au cours
du XXème siècle il y a eu quelques
événements je crois 3 magnitude 6 dans
ce secteur-là d'habitude c'est plus au
nord le long de la faille Nord un
atolienne et d'ailleurs en 1999 c'était
cette faille là située au nord de la
Turquie justement qui avait qui avait
bougé cette feuille là
en fait ouais c'est ça la fin la fin
d'or anatolienne c'est celle qui donne
les plus grands séismes mais celle de ce
matin et d'hier soir c'était plus la
faille est anatolienne et celle-là elle
est moins active toutefois son potentiel
avait été reconnu dans le zonage
sismique de Turquie une troisième zone
c'est aussi plus en direction de la
Grèce le long de la côte ça aussi on a
des séismes qui sont ressentis et tout
ça c'est du justement à l'interaction
des plaques tectoniques et c'est ça qui
amène justement l'accumulation de
contraintes et le relâchement d'énergie
lorsque il y a justement ces grands
séismes là bon on disait un premier
séisme à 20h17 hier soir un autre 9
heures plus tard de magnitude 7,5 est-ce
que c'est fréquent deux séismes parce
que les autorités turques parlent
vraiment d'un deuxième séisme en fait
absolument et donc généralement les
répliques sismiques vont être plus
faibles que le choc principal c'est le
cas mais 7.5 par rapport à cette fois 9
c'est vraiment proche en termes
d'énergie relâché alors le deuxième
événement pour l'information qu'on a ce
n'est pas la même feuille qui a retiré
c'est une faille régionale située un peu
au nord de l'autre avec un angle et ce
qui arrive c'est lorsque vous avez un
magnitude 7.8 c'est qu'on perturbe si
vous voulez la stabilité des failles et
d'autres faits justement c'est l'espèce
de petite poussée qui leur manquait pour
justement relâcher leur énergie et c'est
pour ça que le deuxième événement
n'affecte pas la même région que le
premier c'est vraiment dans le coin
c'est dans le coin nord-est de la faille
qui avait bougé hier soir alors on n'a
pas beaucoup de nouvelles de cette
région là mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut
craindre donc maintenant après autant
d'activités sismiques là
bien malheureusement pour les gens
là-bas il y aurait des répliques
sismiques pendant les jours et
probablement même les semaines à venir
le nombre de ces répliques-là va
diminuer avec le temps mais de temps à
autre malheureusement il y aura des
événements plus forts qui pourraient
être ressentis et dans quelques cas
justement ajouter déjà au dommages
malheureusement évidemment l'autre
facteur là qui explique ce bilan
catastrophique c'est aussi la fragilité
de certains bâtiments qu'est-ce que ça
vous dit sur les images on voit des
immeubles qui tiennent encore debout
d'autres qui sont qui sont écroulés
comme des châteaux de cartes oui c'est
ça parfois on a vu justement certains
édifices relativement semblables
certains tenaient toujours debout et
d'autres ne tenaient pas ça peut être dû
par exemple à des conditions de sol bien
bien locales à ce moment-là qui ou le
sol peut amplifier les ondes sismiques
ça peut être des vis de construction
justement qui font que certains édifices
s'écroulent à l'échelle plus de la zone
affectée à ce moment-là ça pourrait être
dû au tremblement de terre lui-même
parfois on voit lorsqu'il y a un
glissement le long d'une feuille ça va
concentrer l'énergie dans certaines
directions on appelle ça un mouvement de
préférence finalement pour les grands
mouvements localement ça peut être des
conditions de sol et comme on vient de
dire parfois des vis de construction ou
parfois des édifices trop vieux qui ne
répondent pas aux normes actuelles
c'est la montagne merci beaucoup pour
tous ces détails on comprend mieux
maintenant ce qui s'est passé merci je
vous en prie